zu stemmen wir werden spüren dass nach
der pandemie europa unter großem druck
gerät und wir wollen ein europäisches
deutschland prägen und dafür eintreten
wir wollen dass das aufstiegsversprechen
erneuert wird
kinder haben ganz besonders unter dieser
pandemie gelitten aber es bleibt unser
ziel dass jedem kind unabhängig von der
herkunft der eltern der aufstieg in
unserem land möglich wird und wir wollen
ein deutschland das vorbild ist in der
welt durch exzellenz durch innovation
und durch menschlichkeit
auch wir werden unseren
kanzlerkandidaten in cdu und csu bald
bestimmen
ich freue mich über das votum das
einhellige meinungsbild des
bundesvorstands in der letzten woche in
unserem bundesvorstand sind vertreten
die vertreter aller landesverbände aber
auch aller vereinigungen des
wirtschaftsflügels und des sozialflügels
der kommunalen ebene und der
europäischen ebene also eine breite
repräsentanz unserer basis und ich habe
für heute 18 uhr den bundesvorstand
eingeladen im lichte der gespräche der
letzten tage die situation zu beraten
und ich werde den bundesvorstand einen
vorschlag machen wie wir jetzt sehr
schnell die nicht geklärte frage
zwischen cdu und csu
auflösen ich finde wir müssen viel
miteinander im gespräch seien im moment
und habe deshalb auch markus söder
eingeladen an dieser sitzung
teilzunehmen ebenso wie ich bereit bin
in den csu vorstand zu gehen
gerade in diesen tagen müssen wir sehr
viel miteinander reden denn das ziel ist
dass die union diese bundestagswahl
gewinnt und das geht nur mit viel
gemeinsamkeit und viel gemeinsamen
kontakt mit einem gemeinsamen
wahlprogramm und einer gemeinsamen
person als kanzlerkandidat und wie wir
dahin kommen das werden wir heute abend
im bundesvorstand beraten
ich werde einen vorschlag unterbreiten
und ich hoffe dass wir dann sehr schnell
in dieser woche zu den erforderlichen
entscheidungen kommen
ich danke ihnen dass sie da waren und
wünsche ihnen weiterhin einen guten
heute sonnigen tag hier in berlin
[Musik]
laschet dem cdu parteivorsitzenden der
sich wie gesagt ja noch mit markus söder
in einer auseinandersetzung befindet
darüber wer denn der kanzlerkandidat der
union werden soll vielleicht ganz kurze
inhaltliche hat seine pläne für
deutschland skizziert und hat gesagt
dass der kandidat bald bestimmt werden
wird er hat den parteivorstand für heute
abend 18 uhr eingeladen in diesem
vorstand sind einige stimmen und
strömungen vertreten und die sollen
natürlich dann auch noch mal gehört
werden und wir wollen darüber sprechen
mit nicole diekmann
sie ist uns wieder zugeschaltet heute
vormittag nicole haben ja schon über die
grünen gesprochen jetzt geht es also um
die union und um armin laschet wie hat
sein auftritt gerade auf dich gewirkt
weil er einmal ist ja chronologie immer
eine wichtige komponente in der politik
wer ist der schnellere das war schon
ganz interessant zu sehen es gab heute
vormittag schon die ankündigung
du hast ja heute morgen auch noch mal
erwähnt oder heute mittag als sie über
die grünen sprachen um 14 uhr hatte
markus söder geladen zur pressekonferenz
in münchen
und dann kam die einladung aus dem
konrad-adenauer-haus hier in berlin
parteizentrale der cdu deren chef armin
laschet ja ist der große kontrahent von
markus söder
um die kanzlerkandidatur der union
familie hat weil er sich zur
kanzlerkandidatur frage der grünen um 13
uhr also eine stunde vor söder äußern
das heißt er will den punkt setzen er
wollte vor wieder vor die kameras treten
das hat er jetzt getan
er schien sehr locker zu sein war sehr
freundlich hat gelächelt zum abschied
noch mal einen schönen sonnigen tag
gewünscht also es war sehr wichtig nicht
nur der erste heute zu sein der in den
medien frisch vorkommt sondern auch als
souveräner und immer noch optimistischer
aspirant auf diese kanzlerkandidatur
shot kameras und die mikrofone zu treten
nicole reden gleich weiter würde gerne
noch für unsere user kurze anbieten dass
wir noch mal gemeinsam auf die situation
schauen auf die chronologie und auch auf
die aktuelle vor allem lage und mein
kollege andreas kühner ist hat noch mal
die wichtigsten ereignisse so zu sagen
bis hierhin und in den letzten stunden
zusammen getragen
als armin laschet vergangenen nacht zu
einem weiteren treffen mit markus söder
aufbricht scheint er genauso fest
entschlossen zu sein nicht aufzugeben
wie sein widersacher der aus münchen per
privatjet anreist dreieinhalb stunden
muss das gespräch im bundestagsgebäude
gedauert haben ausgang unbekannt
draußen machen weiter die unterstützer
mobil die junge union für süd heute
haben die landesvorsitzenden der jungen
union sich positioniert 14
landesvorsitzende haben dabei ein
stimmungsbild aus ihren landesverbänden
geschildert und gesagt dass sie für
markus söder votieren würden während
söder nach dem gespräch nach bayern
zurück fliegt bleibt laschet in berlin
und sammelt seine truppen zu den
zahlreichen vorschlägen wird am morgen
ein weiterer kommen die basis
entscheiden lassen
das geht relativ zügig kann man in 14
tagen wissen wie die union wirklich über
den spitzenkandidaten denkt am vormittag
trifft der cdu-chef hessens
ministerpräsident bouffier der versucht
zwischen söder und laschet zu vermitteln
auch hier offenbar kein ergebnis
wird morgen die gemeinsame
bundestagsfraktion entscheiden
ich werde jedenfalls einer abstimmung in
der fraktion nicht zustimmen wenn mein
parteivorsitzende armin laschet das
nicht möchte getrennt und gemeinsam
werden am nachmittag cdu und csu weiter
beraten
der kampf um die kanzlerkandidatur wird
zum kampf auf biegen und brechen
der kampf auf biegen und brechen der
sollte es ja eigentlich gerade nicht
sein wenn man letzte woche genau
zugehört hat bei markus söder und auch
bei armin laschet warum ist es jetzt
doch zu einem solchen geworden
ja also der zug ist komplett abgefahren
weil markus söder sich nicht damit
abgefunden hat das cdu präsidium und
vorstand vergangene woche einstimmig für
laschet als kandidaten gestimmt haben
und was dann passiert ist ist das
teilweise mitglieder des vorstands
ministerpräsidenten umgefallen sind der
erste war haseloff einer haseloff
ministerpräsident in sachsen-anhalt der
sich im laufe der vergangenen woche dann
doch so sehr bekannt hat man muss dazu
wissen haseloff hat dieses ist der
nächste ministerpräsident der cdu der
landtagswahl vor sich hat dem sitz die
afg im nacken
generell sind die ostländer der cdu eher
söder lager dann hat sich auch julian
hans tobias als entschuldigung tobias
hans ministerpräsident im saarland in
einem interview mit der welt in der
letzter woche prosa ausgesprochen und
das argument des widerlagers sind die
aktuellen umfragen und da muss man sagen
ich wieder ganz klar fall az
aber ist das nicht sehr riskant denn
umfragen sagen ja nun auch viele sind in
gewisser weise flüchtig und volatil
also ist es nicht einigermaßen heikel
sich auf die umfragen jetzt zu verlassen
es ist aus genau diesem grund und einem
zweiten grund optisch gleichkomme heil
können du hast gerade gesagt die
umfragen sind sehr schnelllebig gerade
in diesem völlig unwägbaren zeiten
während der pandemie jens spahn zum
beispiel bundesgesundheitsminister kann
davon ein lied singen
er wurde zwischenzeitlich mal gehandelt
in tann der mit laschet in dem man ja
angetreten ist
als der bessere parteivorsitzende zu dem
dann der abi laschet bekanntermaßen
gewählt wurde inzwischen sparen in den
umfragen weit zurückgefallen und der
zweite grund warum dieses manöver von
synthes ist er delikt
ich habe mir noch mal an er
delegitimiert demokratische
institutionen partei institutionen wie
vorstand und präsidium
das heißt das was mal gegolten hat gehe
ich jetzt nicht mehr aus guten gründen
so wie sie zusammengesetzt sind
zusammengesetzt die gremien deren wort
haben wenn man so das mokick volk kein
gewicht mehr
und das könnte einen schaden anrichten
nicht nur innerhalb der union
der wahrscheinlich lange brauchen wird
bis man ihm wiederum hat aber wundert
ist dich in diesem zusammenhang nicht
dass die cdu das ja offensichtlich
zumindest in weiten teilen so mit sich
machen lässt denn du hast es gerade
angesprochen
es gibt immer mehr auch prominente
stimmen aus der cdu
die eben nicht widersprechen sondern
sich sogar für sünder aussprechen die
müssten ja eigentlich von diesen
vorgängen entsetzt sein eigentlich es
gibt ja auch genug
es gibt ja genug vertreter auch das darf
man nicht vergessen in der cdu die ihr
weiter hinter laschet stehen diejenigen
die sich dann hinter sieger gestellt
haben die jetzt auch dafür plädieren
morgen in der fraktion das ist ja das
einzige gemeinsame gremium von cdu und
csu von denen schwesterparteien über die
k frage abstimmen zu lassen
die argumentieren eben mit den umfragen
und sagen sich die wollen natürlich auch
nächstes jahr im job haben wir wollen
weiter bundestagsabgeordnete bleiben die
wollen weiter politik machen und auch
wenn es nur eine momentaufnahme ist das
ist was sehr greifbares zahlen sind
nicht relativer und nochmal auch im
zdf-politbarometer der vergangenen woche
war die stimmungslage eindeutig pro
schüler ja die war eindeutig pro schule
das ist genau der punkt also das ist
natürlich für die union beziehungsweise
für die cdu ein problem wenn man so will
zumindest für ein laschet könnte es
jetzt 1 werden er hat gerade gesagt
armin laschet dass er um 18 uhr
den vorstand eingeladen hat und auch
markus söder hat er dazu eingeladen was
ist jetzt von diesem treffen zu erwarten
also glaubst du weil er sagte auch er
würde einen vorschlag machen wollen wie
hört sich das für dich an dass er dann
doch zurückzieht oder in welche richtung
konnte das jetzt gehen
das würde mich sehr wundern also wenn
man sich das jetzt als abi lastet eine
woche lang so gibt warum sollte er dann
heute abend zurückziehen das wären
interessant am ufer so erscheint ja
mindestens genauso entschlossen zu sein
wie markus söder hat ja auch heute sich
noch mal bedankt für das votum des
parteivorstandes von vergangener woche
das ja da noch eindeutig zu seinen
gunsten ausgefallen ist das interessante
an dieser an diesen treffen dass er
einberufen hat ist er hat die hausmacht
er ist der cdu-chef das ist das eine es
geht ja auch immer um symbolik in der
politik und das zweite ist er hat auch
noch mal eben mit blick auf annalena
baerbock bedürfen nicht vergessen
offiziell war der anlass für sein
statement gerade um 13 uhr
dass er sich zur kanzlerkandidatur von
annalena baerbock äußern wollte das hat
er ganz geschickt eingeflochten ist auch
noch einmal auf einer lena berbalk
eingegangen auf die geschlossenheit die
sie heute morgen ja in ihrer rede auch
noch mal betont hat und das ist das
pfund mit dem armin laschet buch harz in
diesem bekennen in diesen kampf gegen
markus söder und auch seine befürworter
erinnern dass sie sagen wie laschet ist
die integrative figur im gegensatz zu
söder und zu sagen wir müssen
miteinander reden das hat er gerade in
seinem statement gesagt dass betont
natürlich noch mal diesen charakter den
er hat und der jetzt wenn man sich
anguckt wie auch anscheinend miteinander
gerade innerhalb der union geredet wird
wie der streit auch innerhalb der cdu
utopie wir hören ist das sehr wichtig
denn man bilder geschlossen in den
wahlkampf ziehen mit welchen kandidaten
dann auch immer weil das sagt angela
stauch man diese wahl natürlich auch
windeln die union die cdu möchte das
kanzleramt nicht preisgeben man möchte
weiter an der regierungsspitze stehen ja
und da ist eben jetzt anscheinend der
dreh den amila stattgefunden hat zu
sagen ich bin der
pa der einlädt und b bin zu mir einlädt
und bin ich derjenige der das der dafür
sorgt dass miteinander gesprochen wird
und dass wir heute abend um 18 uhr
vielleicht doch noch ein geordnetes
verfahren finden denn das ist ja der
witz an dem heutigen tag wir erleben ja
eine verkehrte welt die grünen schaffen
es monatelang dichtzuhalten schaffen es
ganz offensichtlich ohne streit
auszuhandeln wer antritt als
kanzlerkandidatin robert habeck der sich
zurückgenommen hat der jetzt annalena
baerbock den vortritt gelassen hat hat
heute morgen auch noch einmal seine
unterstützung zugesichert das war
erstmal momentaufnahmen sehr harmonische
auftritt der beiden und gleichzeitig
zerlegt sich die in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten bis auf wenige ausnahmen
immer disziplin mehr als geschlossen
nach außen hin auftretende union gerade
selber das ist ja gerade noch mal einen
haken da genau also gerade eben das was
du sagst also das ist ja insofern auch
vor allem bemerkenswert weil die union
ist ja nun auch als markenkern
eigentlich hat dass man eben geschlossen
auftritt und da weiß man ja nun auch
dass die wählerschaft ist ganz und gar
nicht honoriert wenn es innerparteiliche
zerwürfnisse gibt und da lauthals
gestritten wird also gerade vor dem
hintergrund ist es doch ein wirklich
sehr bemerkenswerter vorgang der gerade
stattfindet absolut und dem versucht
amila stellt sich jetzt sicherlich jetzt
auch die abfindungs störungen heute
entschuldigung
mit diesem termin um 18 uhr heute auch
noch mal wenigstens ein bisschen jetzt
wieder dieses bild zu konterkarieren von
diesen zerstrittenen haufen
man hat in der union jahrelang
gespöttelt über die spd die sich ja auch
ständig wieder gegenseitig zerfleischt
hat ja innerhalb der eigenen partei
und man hat an den umfrageergebnissen
und auch den wahlergebnissen gesehen was
das mit der spd angerichtet hat und nun
zieht man da quasi gleich also
unionsanhänger erinnern und bericht
erstatten reiben sich die augen genauso
wie es eben die grünen tun weil
verkehrter welt
ja und es gibt abwanderungsbewegungen
die hat man in der vergangenheit schon
gesehen zu den grünen auch zur afd
teilweise natürlich auch zur fdp
also ist das ein prozess der der union
auch langfristig tatsächlich noch
richtig schaden könnte
der kann ja union langfristig schaden
wie gesagt zerstrittenheit wird von
wenigen bälle erinnern welcher partei
auch immer geschätzt aber auch gerade
konservative mögen solche öffentlich
ausgetragenen schlachten nicht und das
was da gerade passiert ist ja
beispiellos das ist nicht nur
beispiellos für die union also
interessanter war reise ich habe ja eben
schon das zdf-politbarometer letzte
woche erwähnt da war die union wieder
ein bisschen nach oben gegangen
die frage ist aber ob das jetzt erstmal
nur eine momentaufnahme ist die zeit das
interesse an der union ist jetzt erst
mal gewachsen weiter eben gerade so viel
los ist
es ist wirklich schrecklich und ich
würde das auch sehr mit einem dicken
fragezeichen versehen dass wähler innen
einen kanzlerkandidaten goutieren wie
markus söder der völlig rücksichtslos
sich seinen weg eben in diese kandidatur
gewarnt hat auf der anderen seite aber
auch ein ami laschet der als
vorsitzender der viel größeren
schwesterpartei sich eine woche lang
oder wer weiß wie lange das jetzt noch
geht sich so hat vorführen lassen
ja also das ist wie gesagt bemerkenswert
da kann man sich nur wiederholen wir
können gerade noch mal einen blick
riskieren
nach münchen wenn wir warten ja auf die
nächste pressekonferenz wir hatten
darüber gesprochen markus söder 14 uhr
ist sein termin angekündigt und dabei
jetzt armin laschet zuvor gekommen aber
wir sehen gerade dass wir außer dem
gebäude noch nicht sehen wie gesagt sind
ja auch noch gut in der zeit das dauert
noch einen moment und in der zeit bin
ich sehr froh dass unserer hauptstadt
korrespondent in die kolleg mal mit uns
spricht also herr söder wird erwartet
reden wir nochmal kurz über herr laschet
vielleicht nehmen wir auch an der stelle
gerade nochmal unsere user mit ins boot
max knott schreibt über facebook meine
güte er hat viel gesprochen und nichts
gesagt das bezieht sich auf den auftritt
vor hin
er hätte sich zur kanzlerkandidatur
eindeutiger äußern müssen schreibt
holger schmidt über facebook das ganze
hin und her butter bei die fische wird
es da erwartet so weit erst mal diese
stimmen vielleicht gucken wir uns auch
an der stelle noch mal den kandidaten
laschet etwas genauer an wir haben ein
kleines porträt über ihn vorbereitet im
internen unions kanzlerduell gibt
er sich siegesgewiss armin laschet der
60 jährige steht seit 2017 als
ministerpräsident an der spitze der
schwarz gelben regierung in nrw seit
januar ist der cdu bundesvorsitzender
nach einem erbitterten internen
machtkampf laschet gilt in der partei
als liberal und steht er für ein weiter
so nach der ära merkel während der
korona krise gerät der cdu-chef in die
bredouille
da sind diskussionen über öffnung
schritte incidents werte oder
massenbestellungen und nicht zuletzt der
brücken lockdown dabei hagelt es nicht
nur unverständnis von der opposition
sondern auch vom koalitionspartner und
aus den eigenen reihen
das alles drückt einer der wichtigsten
politischen währungen die umfragewerte
lediglich 23 prozent sagten ende märz
und zdf politbarometer armin laschet
würde sich als bundeskanzler eigenen 65
prozent sahen das nicht so
doch laschet und das cdu präsidium geben
sich selbstbewusst
also natürlich sind die
umfrageergebnisse auch erörtert worden
aber alle haben deutlich gemacht und
jeder hatte unzählige beispiele bei der
hand die umfragen sich innerhalb
kürzester zeit auch verändern können
daran muss er jetzt arbeiten fünf monate
zeit bleiben ihn ja wenn man ihn lässt
wenn er sozusagen der kandidat wird dann
bleiben ihm noch fünf monate nicole
diekmann ist ja schon interessant er
hatte jetzt in der partei schon einige
schlachten doch erfolgreich geschlagen
sich am ende dann durchgesetzt warum
sind seine umfragewerte in der
bevölkerung was die kanzlerkandidatur
angeht so schwach das hat zum einen mit
ihm selber zu tun vor allem mit seinem
krisenmanagement jetzt als nrw
ministerpräsident während der kuba-krise
da gab es einige entscheidungen die
leute ihm übel genommen haben er war ja
ja bekannt als derjenige der lok hat und
auf der anderen seite ist eben markus
söder der den großen medialen auftritt
liebt und beherrscht der aufgetreten ist
in dieser pandemie als merkel verstehe
als jemand der die sehr vorsichtige
linie die angela merkel ja vertritt
teilt das ist nur in teilen richtig da
gab es auch widersprüche zwischen seinen
aussagen und und seinen lockerungen die
auch er in bayern veranlasst hat aber
der eindruck ist eben er ist derjenige
der das ganze besser im griff hat ergibt
sich staatsmännisch verliert anders als
ami laschet zum beispiel zuletzt hier im
zdf bei markus lanz oder auch mal bei
einem will vor einigen monaten nicht die
nerven hat die situation im griff
er ist der trainer ganz wirkt souveräner
aber interessanterweise eben auch das
muss man schon auch der wahrheit halber
sagen auch er hat seine position öfter
mal verändert in den letzten jahren das
fällt ihm aber jetzt offenbar momentan
nicht so sehr auf die füße er hat seine
sagtest du mein land geht es nun
wirklich nicht richtig meinte eigentlich
herrn söder entschuldigung ja genau
söder hat seine position sehr verändert
in den vergangenen jahren also
angefangen mit einem begriff wie asyl
tourismus dass er mal verwendet hat
während der sogenannten flüchtlings
diese als die csu in bayern noch
versuchte rechts zu blinken und so der
af de herr zu werden
diese position hat söder inzwischen
geräumt aber das ist ja noch relativ
sagen wir mal radikale positionen da
muss man erst mal hinkommen und dann
muss man auch erstmal wieder wegkommen
und dann hat er sich versucht zu wandeln
und in der wahrnehmung vieler hat er das
anscheinend ja auch geschafft so die
umfragen zu jemanden der eben gesetzt
auftritt der die schrillen töne nicht
mehr wählt der verantwortung übernimmt
für sein bundesland der außerdem seine
liebe zur natur entdeckt hat also auch
versucht eben sich einen grüneren
anstrich zu geben genau markus söder ist
freundlich formuliert sehr flexibel
ja genau und jetzt noch mal die frage
wann macht herr söder seine konferenz
nicht der landung herr söder um den geht
es neben herrn laschet genau und der
macht seine konferenz um 14 uhr das wird
gerade nochmal von terminator über
youtube gefragt und auf diese konferenz
erwarten wir uns sprechen eben in der
zwischenzeit mit nicole diekmann in
berlin ich lese vielleicht gerade noch
den einen oder anderen kommentar vor
andreas müller über facebook schwarz
grün ist wohl nur mit laschet eine
option falls die union bis zur wahl
überhaupt die umfragewerte halten kann
ist dem so oder müsste man sagen vor dem
hintergrund dessen was du gerade
geschildert hast das eben auch wieder
vorstellbar wäre in einer koalition mit
den grünen
wir hatten vergangene woche ein
vorgespräch mit einem relativ
hochrangigen cdu-politiker der sagte
alles ist möglich und das hat er nicht
euphorisch gesagt sondern eher
verzweifelt weil er gerade sieht das
tatsächlich seine partei auch die
schwesterpartei anscheinend zu allem in
der lage ist und das würde ich auch
sagen in bezug auf mögliche
regierungskonstellationen es ist ein
sehr diffuses bild was wir im moment
sehen sind diffuse zeiten es sind viele
unwägbarkeiten vieles unvorhergesehen
ist das passiert aufgrund von corona die
grünen haben sich daher heute mittag ja
schon darüber gesprochen oder heute
formel
annalena baerbock hatten rede gehalten
auf der man nicht sagen konnte aber das
ist also die koalitionsaussage der
grünen das hat sie bewusst offen
gelassen
die grünen wissen das natürlich auch und
das gilt nicht nur für die parteien mit
denen man sich vorstellen kann im rund
zu koalieren sondern auch mit den
kandidaten also söder ist flexibel habe
ich gerade schon gesagt genau hat sich
in sachen bienenschutz sehr stark
gemacht die vergangenen jahre in bayern
also da würde ich erst mal nichts
ausschließen wie casper plattform fragt
und eine ähnliche richtung über youtube
wo liegen eigentlich die inhaltlichen
unterschiede zwischen laschet und söder
kann man das kurz und prägnant auf einen
punkt bringen weil nach dem was ich
bislang eigentlich gelesen und gehört
habe sind die inhaltlichen differenzen
eigentlich gar nicht so groß und das ist
ja auch einer der punkte
warum viele eigentlich großes
unverständnis haben für die situation
wie sie im moment ist weil dann dadurch
doch auch klar wird dass es mehr um
persönliche ambitionen und weniger um
die sache geht
das würde ich gerne vorweg schicken das
kommt in der diskussion im moment viel
zu kurz die inhaltlichen unterschiede
und das ist ganz interessant es geht
jetzt tatsächlich und das ist auch ein
schaden für die unionsparteien im moment
nur noch um charaktere und
charaktereigenschaften um psychogramme
die bezeichnet werden weiter zwei große
egos aufeinander zurasen ungebremst
markus söder ist außenpolitisch nicht so
interessiert das hat er kürzlich mal
gesagt ansonsten wie gesagt auch die
beiden nutzen gerade keinen moment um
sich inhaltlich zu positionieren dass
das findet im moment einfach nicht statt
und das ist eine entpolitisierung von
politik die der gesamten politischen
debatte kultur her nicht gut aber das
passiert gerade wird natürlich auch vom
politischen gegner scharf kritisiert
dass es jetzt doch bald wieder um
inhalte dann auch gehen muss auch vom
koalitionspartner übrigens von der spd
vielen dank für den moment nicole wir
behalten natürlich hier die leitung
wollen aber gerne noch dort färber mit
ins gespräch nehmen wenn sie uns denn
hören kann
kann ich wunderbar da ist wie und ist
uns zugeschaltet aus düsseldorf und ist
natürlich ganz interessant jetzt auch
noch mal die meinungen aus dem
landesstudio dort abzuholen wie wirkte
dann auf dich der auftritt von armin
laschet reden naja man muss sagen armin
laschet war ein bisschen angespannt aber
der mann hat nerven aus stahl seine
besondere widerstandsfähigkeit gerade
auch unter druck die ist bekannt und da
gibt es so zwei ebenen das eine ist der
markus lanz auftritt oder der anne will
auftritt also laschet hat ein hohes
potential regelmäßig wenn er emotional
ist in talkshows da ja sozusagen seine
emotionale seite auch und souverän zu
zeigen die andere seite ist wenn es
drauf ankommt dann liefert er
das war beispielsweise beim
cdu-parteitag so als er gegen zwei
mitbewerber bestehen musste und da
wirklich eine fast perfekte rede an
inszenierte rede hingelegt hat die hat
er geliefert aber das war auch noch kann
man regelmäßig beobachten das ist bei
vielen interviews die er eben in diesen
angespannten situationen gibt auch der
fall wenn er sich so ein bisschen
zurücklehnt und dann irgendwie mal so
reingeht dann wird zahlt regelmäßig
nicht so souverän
derzeit würde ich ihr sagen es geht ja
um alles es geht nicht nur um ihnen
persönlich um die kanzlerkandidatur es
geht natürlich auch um den zusammenhalt
der union es geht um die führung der cdu
derzeit ist der druck so groß dass ich
glaube dass der patzer beim öffentlichen
auftritt eher unwahrscheinlich ist ja
den öffentlichen auftritt von vorhin
denen wollen wir uns gerne auch
gemeinsam noch einmal anschauen dort
vielen dank bislang wir sprechen gleich
weiter weil wir wollen noch mal hören
was armin laschet denn wohin genau
gesagt hat
ja meine damen und herren die grünen
haben heute ihre kanzlerkandidatin
aufgestellt ich gratuliere annalena
baerbock zu dieser wahl und ich kann ihr
zu sagen dass die cdu deutschlands sich
auf einen fairen wahlkampf freut
wir müssen menschlich miteinander fair
umgehen
das muss man ohnehin in wahlkämpfen aber
man muss es ganz besonders in diesen
zeiten der pandemie wo die menschen
existenzielle ängste haben und von den
politikern erwarten dass sie in einer
fairen weise miteinander argumente
austauschen und um den besten weg
bringen
wir wissen aus den usa was es bedeutet
polarisierte wahlkämpfe zu führen und
wir wissen auch wie lange nach einer
demokratischen entscheidung dort ein
neuer präsident gebraucht hat und immer
noch braucht um das land wieder zu
versöhnen
das sollten wir uns in deutschland
ersparen wir sollten unter demokratinnen
und demokraten vom ersten moment an
respektvoll miteinander umgehen
ich kenne annalena baerbock schon lange
auch robert habeck und wir können dieses
versprechen heute noch einmal erneuern
es wird ein fairer ein frischer
vielleicht auch manchmal ein fröhlicher
jedenfalls ein ernsthafter wahlkampf
werden
wir werden in diesem wahlkampf dafür
eintreten die zeit nach der pandemie gut
zu bewältigen
die sozialen die kulturellen die
wirtschaftlichen folgen gemeinsam zu
stemmen
wir werden spüren dass nach der pandemie
europa unter großem druck gerät und wir
wollen ein europäisches deutschland
prägen und dafür eintreten
wir wollen dass das aufstiegsversprechen
erneuert wird
kinder haben ganz besonders unter dieser
pandemie gelitten
aber es bleibt unser ziel dass jedem
kind unabhängig von der herkunft der
eltern der aufstieg in unserem land
möglich wird und wir wollen ein
deutschland das vorbild ist in der welt
durch exzellenz durch innovation und
durch menschlichkeit
auch wir werden unseren
kanzlerkandidaten in cdu und csu bald
bestimmen
ich freue mich über das votum das
einhellige meinungsbild des
bundesvorstands in der letzten woche in
unserem bundesvorstand sind vertreten
die vertreter aller landesverbände aber
auch aller vereinigungen des
wirtschaftsflügels und des sozialflügels
der kommunalen ebene und der
europäischen ebene also eine breite
repräsentanz unserer basis und ich habe
für heute 18 uhr den bundesvorstand
eingeladen im lichte der gespräche der
letzten tage die situation zu beraten
und ich werde den bundesvorstand einen
vorschlag machen wie wir jetzt sehr
schnell die nicht geklärte frage
zwischen cdu und csu
auflösen ich finde wir müssen viel
miteinander im gespräch seien im moment
und habe deshalb auch markus söder
eingeladen an dieser sitzung
teilzunehmen ebenso wie ich bereit bin
in den csu vorstand zu gehen
gerade in diesen tagen müssen wir sehr
viel miteinander reden denn das ziel ist
dass die union diese bundestagswahl
gewinnt und das geht nur mit viel
gemeinsamkeit und
viel gemeinsamen kontakt mit einem
gemeinsamen wahlprogramm und einer
gemeinsamen person als kanzlerkandidat
und wie wir dahin kommen das werden wir
heute abend im bundesvorstand beraten
ich werde einen vorschlag unterbreiten
und ich hoffe dass wir dann sehr schnell
in dieser woche zu den erforderlichen
entscheidungen kommen
ich danke ihnen dass sie da waren und
wünsche ihnen weiterhin einen guten
heute sonnigen tag hier in berlin
ja der tag wird so nicht vielleicht für
armin laschet wissens noch nicht ganz
genau wir sprechen mit dort ferber im
landesstudio in düsseldorf die armin
laschet natürlich gut kennt er hat also
eingeladen heute für 18 uhr den
parteivorstand ein gremium in dem
verschiedene strömungen ja auch
vertreten sind
was ist da zu erwarten was verspricht er
sich wohl davon
naja hatte argumentiert dass er sich in
diesem gremium bereits einen rückhalt
geholt hat vergangene woche
und dass er jetzt ist einen vorschlag
unterbreiten es ging zunächst einmal
darum handlungsfähigkeit zu
demonstrieren und auch in hinsichtlich
des verfahrens vor söder zu sprechen das
hat er nun getan wir warten ja noch auf
die pressekonferenz von markus söder
was er nun vorschlagen wird das ist
natürlich spannend wenn er sagt wir
werden bis ende der woche einen
kandidaten haben dann ist er weniger
davon auszugehen dass heute abend dort
abgestimmt wird das ist auch aus dem
laschet lager nicht wünschenswert weil
man dort immer wieder auf die
größenverhältnisse verweist also wenn
beispielsweise kreisverbände gefragt
würden oder andere parteigremien dann
sind die ja nicht alle gleich oder die
seien nicht alle gleich im ruhrgebiet
beispielsweise 14 kreisverbände 25.000
mitglieder der union der cdu das sind
mehr als in sachsen sachsen anhalt und
mecklenburg zusammen
da werden ideen ventiliert wie online
mitgliederbefragung wobei ich nicht
einzuschätzen vermag wie schnell so
etwas gehen könnte aber wir haben ja
noch nicht 18 uhr es bleibt spannend was
er da vorschlägt wir schauen auch gleich
nach münchen wie gesagt 14 uhr soll es
dann losgehen mit der pressekonferenz
von markus oder dort noch eine frage
dieser termin 14 uhr der stand schon ein
bisschen länger dann kam laschet um 13
uhr dann zu sprechen warum war das so
wichtig für ihn offenbar vor herrn söder
noch mal nach außen zu drehen
mehr zunächst mal weil er gar nicht weiß
was markus söder sagt also wenn markus
söder jetzt einen verfahrensvorschlag
macht dann nimmt er ihm sozusagen das
heft des handelns aus der hand es ging
also darum vor allen dingen
handlungsfähigkeit zu zeigen und selbst
aus dem laschet lager heißt es na ja
vielleicht zögert er immer zu lang
vielleicht hätte er schon springen
müssen vielleicht hätte er auch sagen
sollen also ich ziehe eine karte die
markus söder gar nicht ziehen kann
nämlich ich sage ich gehe auf jeden fall
nach berlin ich würde zur not auch
oppositionsführer also das sind alles
überlegungen die es derzeit gibt aber
wichtig war
ich komme vor markus söder und wenn wir
uns erinnern im vergangenen jahr als es
darum ging wer kandidiert für den
cdu-vorsitz da hatten wir eine ganz
vergleichbare situationen da hatte
friedrich merz seine pressekonferenz
angekündigt bereits und armin laschet
hat sehr kurzfristig die pressekonferenz
ich glaube anderthalb stunden eher waren
es damals daneben tatsächlich auch
durchgeführt
die einschätzungen von dort aber vielen
dank nach düsseldorf und wir schauen
noch mal nach münchen und sehen dort im
moment ein noch leeres rednerpult aber
wir sehen vor allem auch meinem kollegen
alexander pohl der steht nämlich dort
vor der parteizentrale ganz
offensichtlich und mit dem wollte ich
jetzt auch gerne das gespräch führte
alexander hallo und ja natürlich auch an
dich die frage herr söder ist für 14 uhr
terminiert was ist von ihm zu erwarten
gibt es da schon irgendwelche
vermutungen
also ganz erstaunlich finde ich dass es
jetzt eine meldung wonach sich markus
söder im csu präsidium einen
versöhnlichen ton angeschlagen haben
soll sich versöhnlicher geäußert haben
soll dafür habe ich aber noch keine
bestätigung
er soll gesagt haben wenn es eine
cdu-vorstandssitzung gibt und sich der
cdu-vorstand für armin laschet
ausspreche
dann wäre er bereit dieses votum zu
akzeptieren nun haben wir eine ähnliche
äußerung von markus söder schon mal vor
einer woche gehört und wir wissen alle
was danach passiert ist nämlich dass
sich markus söder mitnichten eine
entscheidung des präsidiums und des
vorstands gefügt hätte sondern ganz im
gegenteil versucht hatte auch
erfolgreich versucht hat hierfür sich
noch einmal einen moment um aufzubauen
das heißt die frage wird sein ob
vielleicht markus söder in der
pressekonferenz die um 14 uhr hier
losgehen wird auch einen vorschlag
machen wird auch ein vorschlag
dahingehend wie denn jetzt das verfahren
eigentlich laufen soll um einen
kanzlerkandidaten für die union
auszuwählen klar ist mit seiner
fokussierung auf die parteibasis sprich
auf die kreisverbände auf die
ortsverbände aber auch in die
bundestagsfraktion hinein hat er für
sich nochmal momentum gut machen können
das hätte vielleicht am anfang auch
hätten nur vielleicht nur weniger
erwartet wie viel sich dann doch am ende
noch für ihn aussprechen nicht nur in
der fraktion auch auf der ebene der
ministerpräsidenten die junge union die
sich gestern ganz klar für markus söder
ausgesprochen hat das wird jetzt sehr
spannend sein zu sehen wie sich markus
söder jetzt in dieser pressekonferenz
positioniert in der tat darauf warten
wir alle aber vorher müssen wir
natürlich noch ein bisschen spekulieren
in den letzten tagen war es in der tat
so wie du gerade auch schon geschildert
hast dass markus söder
so wird es jedenfalls etwas an boden
gutmachen konnte und es war erstaunlich
wie viele stimmen ist eben auch aus der
cdu gab die sich für ihn ausgesprochen
haben wie könnte jetzt seine strategie
aussehen würde jetzt auf zeit spielen
wird er versuchen dieses momentum wird
es gerade beschrieben hast für sich
wirken zu lassen das ist dann vielleicht
morgen zu einer entscheidung in der
fraktion kommt oder was ist da denkbar
ja das ist ehrlich gesagt das ist genau
die spannende frage die kann ich ihnen
jetzt auch noch nicht beantworten was
ich was ich bis vor kurzem vermutet
hätte ist dass markus würde auf die
fraktion setzt ich hätte wenn ich mir
angeschaut habe wie markus söder in den
vergangenen tagen
gekämpft hat um kanzlerkandidat zu
werden dann hätte ich heute ihn im
brustton der überzeugung gesagt jawohl
er setzt auf die fraktion nachdem ich
aber jetzt gehört habe dass er sich eben
in der präsidiumssitzung versöhnlicher
geäußert haben soll ist das alles etwas
schwierig zu sagen ich glaube dass
markus söder die die fähigkeit von armin
laschet unterschätzt hat ich glaube dass
er mit seiner zermürbungstaktik gedacht
hat dass er früher einen erfolg haben
wird dass er früher vielleicht noch
entscheidendere teile der cdu zum wanken
bringt bringt vielleicht sogar auf seine
seite bringt insofern ja es ist jetzt
wirklich spannend was dabei herauskommt
wir wollen gerade unsere user noch mal
mit reinem stefanie bei youtube schreibt
söder inszeniert sich neben frau merkel
seit beginn der pandemie als kronprinz
da ist doch lange geplant dass er
kandidat wird kann man dem so ohne
weiteres zustimmen versucht er dieses
image tatsächlich für sich aufzubauen
dass er der sozusagen logische
inhaltlich logische nachfolger ist von
frau merkel
das kann man auf jeden fall sagen das
ist eine strategie die markus so dass
schon sehr lange erfährt wenn sie sich
erinnern an die ganzen corona
pressekonferenzen an die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in berlin
wo markus söder sehr oft neben der
kanzlerin platz genommen hat wenn sie
sich erinnern wie oft markus söder in
der korona politik der kanzlerin
zugestimmt hat sich selbst als vize
vorsitzenden des teams vorsicht und die
vorsitzenden angela merkel bezeichnet
hat dann kann man schon sagen dass er
sich hier als den nachfolger als den
kronprinz wenn sie so wollen sieht man
erinnert sich auch an den besuch von
angela merkel auf schloss herrenchiemsee
all das ist ja sehr fein inszeniert
gewesen von söder mit einem ganz klaren
hintergedanken dass er eben genauso
gesehen werden werden will
wie sieht das gerade beschreiben oder
wie die userin das gerade anspricht dass
es durchaus ein punkt auf den markus
söder immer wieder gesetzt hat wir
wollen gerade noch mal den blick wagen
auf die pressekonferenz ist die
räumlichkeiten wo sie dann abgehalten
wird aber wir sehen noch ist nichts im
gange und können deswegen so hoffe ich
doch das gespräch mit meinem kollegen
alexander pohl noch einmal fortsetzen
also wir waren gerade noch einmal dabei
zu erörtern welche strategie markus
söder wohl jetzt fahren könnte in der
nächsten zeit bzw
so wie er sich auch in den letzten
monaten im schon gezeigt hat eine
interessante geschichte war in den
letzten tagen und auch zu hören die cdu
hat darüber nachgedacht dass wenn söder
sich nicht fügen würde man dann das ist
jetzt nicht ganz neu aber in bayern eben
dann auch sozusagen eine cdu gegründet
um der csu das wasser abzugraben
wie man das ist natürlich dann schon den
konflikt auf die spitze getrieben aber
hat man das in bayern ernst genommen
nein entschuldigung dass ich da so sehr
spontane antwort das ist gut kann ich da
nur sagen
ich glaube dass wie soll ich das jetzt
sagen dass das ist quatsch und muss man
es so zu formulieren also dass die cdu
hier in bayern glaubt sozusagen die die
wähler von der csu cdu hin zu treiben
quasi von markus söder weg zu treiben
hin zu einem anderen cdu-landeschef dann
in bayern
das halte ich für relativ wenig
erfolgsversprechend um es mal vorsichtig
zu formulieren also das ist eine drohung
die absolut ins leere läuft wir hatten
bei der diskussion also 76 bei den
trennungs beschluss ein mal so eine
drohung von von helmut kohl das also
dass die cdu tatsächlich hier in bayern
sozusagen ein rückt irland ist ein
landesverband gründeten dann der konkurs
der csu ernsthaft konkurrenz machen will
das kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht
vorstellen also kein taugliches
druckmittel die einschätzung unseres
leistungspunkten in bayern dankeschön
wir hören uns dann auch später noch mal
vielen dank für die bisherigen
einschätzungen und wollen uns aber bei
der stelle oder an dieser stelle nochmal
anhören was markus söder denn eigentlich
für ein typ ist wer jetzt schon lange
über ihn geredet aber auch hier haben
wir noch einmal ein porträt vorbereitet
lange wurde spekuliert ob er es macht
lange ließ er es offen gemeint ist
markus söder
der csu politiker ist 54 jahre alt und
gibt seit 2008 zehn als
ministerpräsident den takt in bayern an
ein jahr später übernimmt er zusätzlich
den parteivorsitz söder gilt als
zielstrebig steigt in der partei früher
auf als andere und sorgt immer wieder
für diskussionen etwa mit dem kreuz
alles in bayern oder seiner wortwahl in
der asyldebatte massentourismus auf sylt
tourismus als tourismus der protestant
söder hat die csu als minister immer
weiter auf sich ausgerichtet und
versucht der partei einen frischen
anstrich zu geben
in der pandemie inszeniert er sich dann
als kümmerer als staatsmann er setzt auf
klare worte und auf ein vermeintlich
schnelles und hartes durchgreifen
das kommt an 56 prozent sagten ende märz
um zdf-politbarometer markus söder würde
sich als bundeskanzler eignen nur 36
prozent sehen das nicht so
ein vorteil für söder der den zwist
gestern aber noch vermeintlich ausweicht
mein angebot
ich will nichts erzwingen im sowie ist
vielleicht die csu früher gern gemacht
hat sehr lautstark auftretend erzwingen
sondern ein angebot für eine gemeinsame
basis
die cdu-spitze das scheint festzustehen
scheint nicht begeistert von diesem
angebot ja soweit also das porträt über
markus söder und wir sprechen noch mal
mit dort färber aus dem landesstudio in
düsseldorf das ist ja vielleicht auch
ganz interessant wie wird denn herr
söder eigentlich in düsseldorf
wahrgenommen
also innerhalb der cdu hier in nordrhein
westfalen ist es ist laschet land muss
man ganz klar sagen der rückhalt hier
ist einig es gibt ein paar versprengte
leute hier in bei einem wahlkreis einer
abgeordneten aber ansonsten ist ist
wirklich ein großer rückhalt für laschet
etwas anders dürfte das in der
bevölkerung seien mir liegt jetzt keine
eigene umfrage vor söder laschet nur
nordrhein westfalen aber da ist die
unzufriedenheit mit lachs regierung
derzeit recht groß laschet verweist ja
immer wieder darauf dass umfragen sich
ändern aber derzeit sind zwei drittel
mit laschet regierungspolitik nicht
zufrieden
das liegt auch sicher daran an diesem
kommunikationsstil also im gegensatz zu
sünder war er ja zunächst mal team
lockern und hat sich damit auch von der
kanzlerin abgesetzt wobei ich glaube das
ist weniger strategisch war als auch
also sicherlich auch strategisch aber es
entsprach einfach auch armin laschet
grundüberzeugung dass man nicht nur auf
eine seite setzen kann sondern alles
gesamtgesellschaftlich im blick halten
muss als dann die zahlen stiegen war er
eben der befürworter ein von strengeren
maßnahmen
er hat immer gesagt wenn die zahlen
steigen muss man muss man maßnahmen
ergreifen wenn die zahlen sinken kann
man locker
aber das ist natürlich im vergleich zur
sünde eine kommunikationsstrategie die
sehr schwer in der öffentlichkeit zu
vermitteln ist das ist ein hü und hott
ein zickzack-kurs das ist auch etwas was
die leute kritisieren und insoweit ist
natürlich das ansehen von markus söder
der von ban beginn der pandemie haben
eine klare botschaft vermittelt hat wir
müssen aufpassen team um sich team
vorsicht das ist natürlich eine
botschaft die in der bevölkerung hier
auch ankommt ja das können wir
vielleicht dort gerade auch noch mal mit
ein paar zahlen unterfüttern du hattest
die umfrage aus nordrhein westfalen
genannt aber wir haben auch ein zdf
politbarometer vorliegen und da ist eben
zusehen dass markus söder wenn die leute
danach gefragt werden immerhin eine
zustimmung von 63 prozent genießt bei
der frage als bundeskanzlerin oder
kanzler ebene würde sich eignen
und da ist herr söder deutlich vor olaf
scholz und natürlich auch für robert
habeck und erst recht für armin laschet
platziert er jetzt hier gar nicht
auftaucht das ist natürlich ein problem
für armin laschet darum dürfte er selbst
ja auch wissen was glaubst du dorthin
wie versucht er denn dieses problem
anzugehen dass er eben in den umfragen
so schlecht da stimmt ich glaube das
geht er mit seiner politischen erfahrung
an die darin beruht dass er immer
niederlagen hatte und nach diesen
niederlagen wieder aufgestanden ist
man kann man natürlich diskutieren das
ist eine historische situation wenn er
kanzlerkandidat würde es ist noch nie
jemand mit so schlechten umfragen
gestartet ob das überhaupt gelingen
könnte aus diesem tiefen tal überhaupt
jemals wieder herauszukommen
laschets leute verweisen natürlich auch
so etwas wie jens spahn beispielsweise
der umfragen könig noch ende des jahres
war anfang des jahres wurde noch
diskutiert ob er nicht der bessere
cdu-vorsitzender kanzlerkandidat wäre
dessen umfragewerte sind sehr schnell
gesunken also das ist eine erfahrung die
tief in armin laschet steckt durch sein
gesamtes politisches leben zieht sich
das dass er immer wieder sozusagen als
verlierer gehandelt wurde aber letztlich
dann doch weitermachen konnte und ich
glaube dass er einfach darauf setzt dass
ich das eben auch noch mal ändert ob das
der fall sein wird da kann man doch ein
bisschen skeptischer sein aber das wurde
sozusagen auch noch mal das
unterstreichen was wir vorhin gehört
haben dass eventuell söder die zähigkeit
von laschet unterschätzt haben könnte
denn die hat er ja nun ganz
offensichtlich ja also diese fähigkeit
hat er und nicht nur die fähigkeit von
armin laschet wird oft unterschätzt
sondern armin laschet selbst auch wir
können es mal ganz praktisch sagen wenn
markus söder einen raum betritt dann
füllt er den armin laschet ist ein meter
72 groß und hat ein rheinisches naturell
der kommt herein und der füllt keinen
raum
das ist aber nicht zu verwechseln mit
mangelnder führungsstärke er hat selber
darauf verwiesen man wird nicht einfach
so ministerpräsident des größten oder
des bevölkerungsreichsten bundeslandes
er ist auch cdu-vorsitzender geworden
also diese fähigkeit die hat er und es
gibt durchaus auch viele aspekte die die
menschen an ihm schätzen und es sind
nicht nur die cdu parteimitglieder
sondern dieses ausgleichende das sind
etwas was ihnen durchaus auch nach vorne
gebracht aber wir müssen sehen
beispielsweise nordrhein westfalen er
regiert hier mit einer stimme mehrheit
und das in seit vier jahren mit der fdp
da gibt es durchaus auch mal
verwerfungen aber das tut eher
geräuschlos also ein seiner großen
vorteile ist er ist konsensfähig er
hinterlässt bei niemandem verbrannte
erde es gibt eigentlich innerhalb der
cdu auch niemanden der schlecht über
armin laschet redet selbst solche
erzfeinde wie weil sie nicht norbert
röttgen oder die leute die nicht
wohlgesonnen sind äußern sich doch
relativ zurückhaltend und verbindet die
menschen ein das gilt auch für friedrich
merz der er jetzt die lasche kandidatur
unterstützt vermutlich auch mit dem
kalkül dass er leichter minister unter
einem kanzler laschet als unter einem
kanzler söder werden würde aber er
unterstützt die torte wir müssen
unterbrechen denn ein markus söder auf
den wir warten hat das rednerpult
getreten und wir sprechen vielleicht
später noch mal danke schön
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
hier doch hall die draußen zuschauen
weil das interesse glaube ich es relativ
groß wie es weitergeht zunächst mal von
meiner seite herzliche gratulation und
robert zu der nominierung der grünen
partei für die kanzlerkandidatur
das wird sicher ein ganz spannender
wahlkampf werden das wird genau den
platz eins gehen zwischen schwarz und
grün grün und schwarz und es wird
hoffentlich ein fairer guter
argumentativer aber schon ambitioniert
der wahlkampf sind
ich glaube ich würde mich sehr freuen
auf diesen wahlkampf hin zu führen aber
so weit sind wir noch nicht
dazu müssen wir noch die
personalentscheidungen in der union
klären
ich glaube aber und kam bis heute
interessiert und beraten
wir sind alle der meinung die zeit ist
reif dafür
acht tage sind eine gute zeit um
sinnvoll und vernünftig zu diskutieren
es geht dabei so einer entscheidung eine
ganze menge
es geht um den anspruch in deutschland
und dieses land und viele viele
millionen menschen in die zukunft
begleiten zu dürfen
aber irgendwann sind alle argumente
gefällt alles ist gesagt und es muss
dann auch entschieden werden
armin laschet und ich hatten mehrere
gespräche gute freundschaftliche
gespräche ohne abschließendes ergebnis
und gestern abend haben wir das noch mal
breiter runde gehabt da war das in
ähnlicher form beim argumente gewogen
ausgetauscht und auch darüber geredet
was unser land braucht und wie wir die
beiden unionsschwestern dabei gut auf
den weg bringen können
das csu präsidium hat heute und zu
rückendeckung gegeben für das was ich
ihnen jetzt sage und diese rückendeckung
kommt nicht nur aus dem präsidium
sondern auch aus unserer basis und auch
aus der breite der fraktionen was ich
vor über einer woche gesagt habe das
gilt natürlich auch jetzt ich persönlich
bin bereit verantwortung zu übernehmen
und mich zu 100 prozent in den dienst
unseres landes und der menschen zu
stellen
dazu bin ich bereit bin und das gilt
wenn eine breite mehrheit der cdu dies
will und trägt es wird ein schwieriger
wahlkampf mit vielen anfeindungen
insbesondere von afg und anderen rechts
und linksaußen gruppen und deswegen wird
es eine große herausforderung sein in
diesen zeiten nicht nur wahlkampf zu
machen sondern auch erfolgreich zu sein
deswegen braucht es gerade weil es so
eine schwierige zeit ist daher braucht
es vollen rückhalt aller wir können nur
als team gewinnen cdu und csu gemeinsam
ein großes team zwei starke parteien
aber ein großes team
deswegen ist uns wichtig und das möchte
ich betonen
es handelt sich bei dieser ganz
entscheidenden personalfrage nicht um
einen streit von cdu csu
sondern es geht um eine letztliche
entscheidung und diskussion innerhalb
der cdu deswegen haben wir auch in den
letzten acht tagen ich hoffe sie haben
das auch so wahrgenommen kein einziges
böses wort aus der csu gefällt mir geht
es in dieser zeit auch ganz wichtig
nicht nur um das ergebnis mit geht es
auch um stil und anstand um souveränität
natürlich ist es so dass wir
konzentriert solche debatten führen
müssen
aber sie müssen am ende so stattfinden
dass wir uns nicht nur in die augen
schauen können sondern nach auch
gemeinsam erfolgreich sein können
deswegen ist es jetzt keine zeit wie
1976 1979 oder schon gar nicht wie 20 18
was ich vor einer woche gesagt habe in
der fraktion also bestellt bei dem
fraktionsvorstand in berlin vor den
kameras das gilt breite unterstützung
heißt ich habe das wort wörtlich so
gesagt kann man auch nach sehen ist wenn
vorstand fraktion und basis das
gemeinschaftlich wollen das geht
übrigens sogar zurück auf einen
beschluss der cdu vom 14
september 2020 wo der vorstand damals
entschieden hat dass in der k-frage ist
wichtig ist dass partei und mitglieder
eingebunden sind in dem prozess
das heißt wir haben uns da ganz streng
sozusagen an die vorgaben auch gehalten
ich empfinde das als teil der demokratie
ich habe ausdrücklich und dass da kein
missverständnis aufkommt ausdrücklichen
respekt vor allen gremien
ich bin seit 38 jahren in der csu und
ich glaube seit 36 jahren mitglied von
gremien
ich schätze das sehr ich bin ein
anhänger und verteidiger der
repräsentativen demokratie
das ist auch der grund warum ich einer
der hauptfeinde der afg in die afg
versucht tagtäglich an den anschlag auf
diesen repräsentativen demokratie
charakter zu machen und ich bleibe dabei
egal wie das ausgeht ich werde ja meinen
schutz versprechen für unsere demokratie
immer wieder erneuern und auch
darstellen also respekt vor den gremien
ist selbstverständlich aber ist auch
wichtig respekt und interesse für
mitglieder abgeordnete und vor allem für
die bevölkerung draußen zu finden die
uns letztlich trägt und
in deren einklang wir sein wollen eine
moderne repräsentative demokratie
vereint beides und denkt gemeinsam die
gremien aber umgekehrt auch die
bevölkerung und in mitglieder die uns
hier tragen also eine woche diskussion
alle waren damit befasst und sind es bis
in den nächsten stunden noch wie ich
höre in den debatten und
diskussionsforen auch das ist heute
anders als vor 20 30 jahren
die leute diskutieren über das internet
sie diskutieren in chatforen sie
besprechen sich und sie bilden meinen
alle argumente sind auf dem tisch das
für und wider das artikuliert und dann
erstes zwischenergebnis gibt es gibt ein
meinungs- und stimmungsbild es gibt
zuspruch für meine bereitschaft aus den
landesverbänden der cdu den
arbeitsgemeinschaften es gibt zuspruch
aus der fraktion von letzter woche sie
wissen ist und es gibt auch zuspruch aus
der bevölkerung was ich bemerkenswert
finde man soll umfragen in der tat nicht
überschätzen aber sie sind eines der
wenigen eines der wenigen die maßstäbe
die rahmen moment und zu entscheidungen
zu hinterfragen
wir sind in den umfragen als union sogar
etwas gestiegen obwohl die woche
natürlich für alle recht
nervenaufreibend ist und auch nicht ganz
einfach ist jetzt meine bitte und noch
einmal eine klare klare aussage bitte an
die cdu jetzt das meinungsbild ihm
abzuwenden und das wird dann auch
gemeinsam abschließen
wo und wie entscheidet die cdu allein
und auch welches gremium das ist wenn
der bundesvorstand es ist dann werden
wir das respektieren genauso wie jede
andere entscheidung ich habe gehört
heute abend ist ja eine beratung armin
laschet hat
ich habe es vorhin gelesen dass wir
abend eine entscheidung sie haben ja
vorher noch eine sms geschickt dazu dass
heute abend der bundesvorstand takt ich
glaube dass auch klug dass dort offen
frei und intern diskutiert wird über die
weiteren wege wie wir das ganze
gestalten wollen
ich habe da total respekt davor will
mich auch nicht einmischen darum ist aus
meiner sicht klar dass wir weil armin
jetzt auch nicht bei uns heute sein
konnte aufgrund der zeit dass wir das
auch jeweils in der jeweiligen familie
diskutieren und dann am ende
später gemeinsam zusammenführen ich sage
ausdrücklich wir als csu
und auch ich wir respektieren jede
entscheidung meine bereitschaft war und
ist immer ein angebot ein angebot zur
unterstützung ein angebot für unser land
und für die union einen wichtigen
vielleicht den zentralen beitrag zu
leisten um am ende erfolgreich zu sein
aber die entscheidung darüber ob dieses
angebot angenommen werden kann oder
nicht ist kann nur die cdu letztlich
treffen sie ist die größere schwester
es wird sie auch immer bleiben und
deswegen egal wie das ausgeht ohne groll
wie entschieden wird da bleibt
jedenfalls blamieren uns nichts hängen
wir müssen egal wie es ausgeht versöhnen
zusammenführen und zu einer gemeinsamen
großen schlagkräftigen einheit in diesem
wahlkampf werden so dass wir überall in
deutschland erfolgreich sind
es geht in dem fall nicht nur in bayern
es geht tatsächlich um deutschland wenn
es um deutschland geht
auch in europa hat heute morgen ich habe
irgendwo gelesen gesagt wir wollten ist
beide aber am ende kann es nur einer
machen den satz eines grünen
unterschreibe ich ganz hundertprozentig
das gilt für uns auch deswegen ist für
mich auch klar wird dass armin hat er
meine volle unterstützung und die
rückendeckung der csu und da kann er
sich dann zu 100 prozent darauf
verlassen im wahlkampf soll das
umgekehrt sein und ich mit ihnen
gemeinsam an der stelle stehen dann
hoffe ich das genauso und teilt dies für
richtig dass es klappt also fazit zeit
für entscheidung ist da danach nach
dieser entscheidung werden wir beraten
ist dann weitergeht wie wir uns
inhaltlich aufstellen und wann und wie
der wahlkampf beginnt ich glaube
allerdings dass der wahlkampf noch eine
zeit braucht denn neben der spannenden
k-frage bedrängt uns gemeinsam auch die
c frage die korona frage die krone
zahlen laufen uns leider davon es gibt
keine entspannung an der krone front im
gegenteil die tief betten werden
zunehmend belegt und es werden häufig
schon kritische situationen gemeldet
deswegen müssen uns mit aller kraft
darauf konzentrieren die notbremse auf
bundesebene zu vereinbaren ist
ganz wichtiger schritt ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob es schon eine garantie ist das
ist der letzte schritt ist und vor allen
dingen ob es der einzige wir müssen es
flankieren mit intelligenten konzepten
mit mehr testen und vor allen dingen
mehr impfen wenn dafür auch der normalen
bayern aber auf nationaler ebene
gemeinsame vorschläge machen weil ich
glaube dass es jetzt ein
ineinandergreifen geben muss zwischen
notbremse und vollgas fürs impfen
das muss miteinander in eine
einheitliche struktur gebracht werden
aber ich sag das aus tiefer überzeugung
wir werden nicht nur eine gute lösung
finden für die personalfrage also ich
bin der tiefen überzeugung wir werden
corona überwinden das war ich und ich
bin ich und es bleibe ich auch und ich
bin auch sicher dass wir eine gute
zukunft für unser land schaffen werden
eine einladende politik zu machen keine
ausgrenzende keine spalten eine
einladende politik eine politik die es
schafft wohlstand freiheit und gesundes
leben für umwelt und die menschen
miteinander einklang zu bringen das ist
die die zentrale schlüsselfrage für den
wahlkampf nicht umwelt gegen wirtschaft
auseinander dividieren nicht freiheit
gegen sicherheit in stellung bringen
sondern ist zu schaffen am ende diese
weltoffenheit und bodenständigkeit
diesem starken start mit einer modernen
gesellschaft den eingang zu bringen das
ist die eigentliche aufgabe die wir
haben und ich glaube da bringen wir als
union zwei dinge mit die uns helfen
natürlich regierungserfahrung ich glaube
schon dass das eine rolle spielt wenn
man voller ideen ist aber gar nicht weiß
wie man regiert dann ist es nicht
einfach umgekehrt nur
regierungserfahrung wäre zu wenig wenn
man nicht vor ideen sprüht und neue
antworten hat auf neue fragen ich glaube
wir können als union beides bringen
erneuerung auf der einen seite und auf
der anderen seite beständigkeit dass
sich auch ein beitrag den ich erbringen
könnte aber das kommt später
am ende habe ich letzte rückfahrt am
ende wird alles gut
ich danke für die unterstützung die
bislang schon erfolgt ist ich bitte auch
um verständnis und verzeihung an alle
dass es eben etwas gedauert hat wir
brauchen noch ein klein bisschen geduld
aber es wird nicht mehr lange dauern
ich bin sicher es wird bald zu einer
guten entscheidung komme hinter der sich
dann am ende alle versammeln wollen was
sagen können und versammeln müssen und
ich werde meinen beitrag dazu bringen in
jedem fall
vielen dank meine damen und herren die
sitzung des csu-präsidiums heute macht
deutlich wir hatten jetzt eine woche der
beratung und jetzt kommen jetzt die tage
der entscheidung das präsidium hat sich
klar hinter markus söder gestellt wenn
wir sehen ehrlich gesagt einen
unglaublichen zuspruch im ganzen land
hier bei unseren abgeordneten in der csu
landesleitung zuspruch in form von
zuschriften in form von zurufen wir
sehen auch einen aufschwung in den
umfragen ich will das ganz deutlich
sagen wir stehen nicht da wo wir stehen
wollen aber wir sehen dass wir die
tiefpunkte der letzten wochen hinter uns
gelassen haben und wir haben auch ganz
klare erwartungen aus den teilen der
schwesterpartei an uns als csu und auch
an markus söder
das präsidium hat sich heute geschlossen
nicht nur der markus söder gestellt
sondern auch in der seinen vorschlag zum
weiteren verfahren nämlich jede
entscheidung die jetzt kommt im zuge der
abschließenden meinungsbildung dann auch
zu akzeptieren denn wir wissen am ende
sind wir nur dann stark wenn wir
geschlossen sind das heißt aber die
meinungsbildung in der union und gerade
auch in der cdu die muss nun rasch zum
ende kommen
ich mache noch mal ganz deutlich
parteilose markus söder hat es schon
unterstrichen es ist kein thema zwischen
cdu und csu
wir wollen und wir werden nicht die
spaltung der union sehen ganz im
gegenteil wir wollen die einheit der
union unser angebot steht mit markus
söder haben wir jemanden der begeistert
der begeistert die csu die union und die
menschen und zwar im ganzen land und
lasse mich persönlich noch sagen ich
glaube wir haben mit ihm ein verdammt
gutes angebot nämlich jemand der modern
ist weiß um deutschland geht wie es bei
der cdu so schön heißt wegen morgen
hätte zwei fragen hat sich wieder können
sie bitte noch mal sagen
zum zeitplan bis wann nach ihrer
einschätzung oder bis wann sie fordern
dass eine entscheidung getroffen werden
muss heute abend im vorstand oder bis
spätestens wie würden sie im zweifel zu
einem zur abstimmung in der fraktion
oder zu einer mitgliederbefragung stehen
und zum zweiten wie groß sehen sie nach
dieser krisenwoche den schaden für die
union insgesamt wenn man vergleicht wie
geräuschlos und haben es bei den grünen
heute gelaufen ist
danke also das erste das entscheidet
jetzt die cdu erst mal souverän
wir machen hier keine vorgaben wir
fordern auch nichts und ist eine bitte
hat so ist genauso wie es formuliert
meine bitte dass wir da jetzt zu
ergebnissen kommen und ich glaube da ist
allseits das bewusstsein dafür da wir
haben in lassing nicht genau das gleiche
bewusstsein zu der sache
der vorschlag würde auch kommen und
ändern wir dann auch respektieren
das finde ich es auch richtig so wir
sind auch die kleinere schwester wir
können hier nicht ums überleben möchte
das zweite der schaden nach
traditionellen muster könnte man das
glauben dass eine woche diskussion dass
das ganze vielleicht schwierig ist aber
ich habe das gefühl mein gefühl sagt zum
einmal das ist alles sehr seriös
diskutiert wurde klar offen netz als bei
den grünen bei den königs heute eine
meldung ist gut wir haben natürlich
jetzt ein entscheidungsprozess an dem
die öffentlichkeit auch mit großem
herzblut teilnimmt nicht nur die
journalisten sondern auch die menschen
das zeigt übrigens was man der union
auch an führungskraft zutraut so
empfinde ich das
und wenn es jetzt mit stil und anstand
auch am ende zum ergebnis für das ist
ganz entscheidend ergebnis entscheidend
egal wie es ist dann glaube ich wird es
uns er möglicherweise sogar stärken weil
es auch eine selbstvergewisserung
justiert stattfindet das ist mir machen
wir keine keine formelkompromisse wir
haben uns ernsthaft mühe gegeben und
auch mein persönlicher respekt und dank
an armin laschet bislang für die art wie
wir das diskutiert haben es ist auch gar
nicht so leicht miteinander solche
schwierigen fragen zu bewerten ich
glaube dass das bislang wirklich sehr
gut gelaufen ist das ist auch bei mir
klar dass die menschliche brücke am ende
dieses langen prozess ist trägt sie
trägt auch weiter und zwar egal ob jetzt
eine die nummer eins ist in unserem team
oder oder ich diese aufgabe schultern
muss ich glaube wir kommen da sehr sehr
gut zusammen und wenn ich dann habe ich
verstanden habe ist es ihm auch nicht
leicht gefallen was ich übrigens auch
menschlich verstehe weil es keine so
leicht fällt bei so einer schweren
entscheidung aber am ende ist wichtig
was hinten rauskommt da bin ich sicher
kommen wir zu einem guten ergebnis und
ich habe die letzte woche das versucht
auch jetzt das wird zu einem
ordentlichen gemeinsame miteinander
finden ich habe gelesen was manch einer
gesagt und geschrieben hat wird das
bewertet habe das alles auch auf mich
wirken lassen
und da gibt es auch sehr kluge argumente
wie das ist aber eins würde ich noch
sagen demokratie darf niemals so
verstanden werden als etwas störendes
demokratie darf nie verstanden werden
als etwas wie kann man sich anmaßen die
meinung von von allen hören zu wollen
ich glaube dass die union heute eine
viel modernere bürgerpartei ist als je
zuvor war und den anspruch haben wir
gezeigt und ich glaube er sogar dass es
die menschen begeistert glaubt der grüne
prozess heute einerseits schnell ja wohl
aber ich glaube dass wir uns da einfach
mehr mühe gegeben aber am ende wird man
sehen wie es bei den menschen ankommt
ist wenn man dann plötzlich abwägen und
10 ende september
ich habe auch ich habe auch zwei fragen
die erste ist wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe sagen sie jetzt wenn der
bundesvorstand das gremium ist bei den
die cdu entscheidet über den
kanzlerkandidaten dann werden sie das
votum akzeptieren
sprich was dann heute abend vielleicht
auch feld was ist der unterschied zu
letzter woche wo sie das ja eigentlich
nichts verstanden auch schon gesagt
haben was er sich verändert und hätten
sie nicht wenn sie es gleich akzeptiert
hätten der union eine menge ärger
erspart das wäre meine erste frage und
die zweite frage mit blick auf die
grünen
wie stehen sie dann zu einer möglichen
schwarz grünen koalition nach der
bundestagswahl
und für wie groß halten sie die
inhaltlichen differenzen beim thema
klima landwirtschaft und flüchtlinge
also erstens wenn sie noch einmal genau
hinein hören die aufnahme des zdf
bestehen der umfangreich zur verfügung
dann hören sie noch mal eindeutig was
ich gesagt habe breite unterstützung in
der cdu und die breite ist von mir
ausdrücklich wortwörtlich so definiert
worden
vorstand ganz wichtig fraktion ganz
wichtig deswegen haben wir uns ja dort
auch glaube ich im austausch gemeinsam
auch in fairer weise gestellt und auch
was die basis betrifft ich glaube diese
woche bereits 1000 wendig um hinein zu
horchen
und wenn sie sehen wird es hat ja ein
breites stimmungsbild gegeben
ich glaube dass das dass es den beiden
volksparteien unglaublich gut tut dass
es solche prozesse gibt weil am ende
muss man sie zusammenführen
es entspricht auch einem ich habe es
vorhin erwähnt einen beschlussvorschlag
dass wir glaube ich dass das eben kein
schaden ist ganz im gegenteil das ist
ein gewinn und ich respektiere jedes
ergebnis des am ende stehen dort das
sage ich ausdrücklich da gibt es dann
keinen nach kabeln oder uminterpretieren
das ist dann halt so wie es ist ja
wichtig ist dass in einem solchen
prozess argumente gewichtet und wir
haben ja nur letztlich ein kriterium ist
uns alle verbindet das sind die
erfolgschancen für uns gemeinsam das ist
glaube ich das was dann zählt das zweite
was die grünen betrifft nun die grünen
haben in dem programmentwurf den sie
letzten vorgelegt haben leider an
einigen stellen
den sprung in die neuzeit nicht so
gemacht wie ich erhofft hatte
natürlich haben die grünen der
umweltpolitik frische und gute ideen
aber der wirtschafts und sozialpolitik
kommt es immer auf dieselbe auf dieselbe
auf denselben ideologischen kern wert
darin lautet höhere steuern höhere
schulden mehr bürokratie und eher
restriktive verbote stadt eine
einladende in die freiheit zitiert wie
es am ende ausgeht im herbst das
fernsehen
unser ziel ist klar zu machen dass wir
den führungsanspruch haben und der
führungsanspruch definiert sich für mich
nicht darin die beste wirtschaftspolitik
in klassischen sinn zu machen
also wenn sie an schon die fdp zum
beispiel macht eine maximale liberale
wirtschaftspolitik so für auch bestimmte
gruppen
die grünen haben in ihrem programm einen
sehr starken freies fordert versuch
eines frei dies verfügte ankers zulegen
das ist in der praxis ein bisschen
wackelig deswegen dann auch die grünen
jetzt mehr denn je in diesem wahlkampf
natürlich sozusagen den faktencheck
machen müssen so wie bei uns täglich
stattfindet nämlich die frage ist der
anspruch der wirklichkeit wirklich so
übereinstimmend
oder ist es nicht so dass es auch da
durchaus risse gibt sie decken ist zum
teil alle sehr engagiert auf und zu
recht und das zweite ist
ich glaube es kommt aber nicht darauf an
wer macht die beste oder die maximalste
umweltpolitik wehrmacht die alle
allerbeste liberalste manchester politik
sondern wer versucht und hofft und kann
es schaffen dass wir beides miteinander
denken wohlstand und nachhaltigkeit zu
halten ich möchte schon dass deutschland
ein
ein role model dafür wird für einen
green deal für einen kleinen deal der es
schafft dass wir unsere erwartungen an
eine eine gesunde und moderne
lebensführung vereinbaren können mit der
chance für uns alle auch arbeitsplätze
der zukunft zweiten das spielt die
digitalisierung eine zentrale rolle
aber das spielt auch die art und weise
wie wir wirtschaft organisieren einen
richtigen content da glaube ich können
wir den führungsanspruch für unser land
ganz gut definieren
also das ist die entscheidende frage ein
starker staat mit vielen schutz
versprechen die wir abgeben
übrigens auch ein schutz versprechen für
minderheiten ein schutz versprechen für
die demokratie ein schutz versprechen
für die nicht so finanziell stark sind
ein schutz versprechen auch gegen
diejenigen die versuchen uns täglich
dieses staates zu bedrohen und umgekehrt
an der moderne gesellschaft in der leben
und leben lassen zählt in dem wir nicht
von antiquierten gesellschafts bildern
ausgehen sondern mit einer mit einem
großen freiheits liberalen gedanken
herangehen werden das ist aus sicht für
mich das ganz entscheidende unter ich
weiß ich verwende da auch moderne
begriffspaare ja aber ich glaube auf
diese neuen fragen der zeit brauchen wir
neue antworten
im moment geht es jetzt nicht die frage
wer mit wem koalieren könnte sondern wie
es die nummer 1 den daraus ergibt sich
ob es am ende eine regierung der grünen
gibt mit anderen oder eine führung der
union mit beispielsweise den grünen oder
beispielsweise mit anderen auf jeden
fall schwarz grün wäre ja möglicherweise
dann die nächste große jedenfalls da
hält sich das so an muss man mal sehen
wie das dann so wird wir sind da jetzt
im moment erstmal auf unsere aufgabe
konzentriert auf die programm aufgabe
konzentriert der generalsekretäre und
dann folgt das andere eins nach dem
anderen
stück für stück schritt für schritt
stefan meyer vom bayerischen rundfunk
bitte wenn das cd der cdu vorstand heute
sich eindeutig für armin laschet
ausspricht ist er dann der kanzler
kandidat von cdu und csu
und die zweite frage wie schnell dran
hängen darf haben die gleich noch nicht
an ein frage haben die grünen vorgemacht
wie es geht an kandidaten zu finden
zweitens nur bescheiden die grünen ist
es für richtig halten ich finde es muss
wie eine bewerten die grünen ihren weg
und ihre in stil und das ist zu
respektieren aber nicht zu kopieren
wir entscheiden nicht von zeit und
inhalt wie dies die grünen machen
sondern grünen machen erst und wir
machen unsere wir haben wir noch eine
andere herausforderung sind bei den
grünen auch in ein sich viel leichter
die grünen hatten ihren kanzler in
deutschland auf ein kanzlerin und die
grünen haben sich erstmals entschieden
diesen anspruch zu definieren an dem
anspruch muss man sich übrigens auch
messen lassen
dem anspruch ein mal eins in deutschland
zu sein muss man sich in gleicher weise
messen lassen
das ist kein spaß und kein spiel sondern
ist schon eine ernsthafte
herausforderung und das war mal sehen
und da wird wird spannende duelle geben
und ich glaube die kann man gut gut
argumentativ bestehen und ist andere
wenn die cdu heute abend souveränen eine
klare entscheidung trifft dann werden
wir das akzeptieren das habe ich jetzt
glaube ich drei vier mal gesagt insofern
also ja was soll es denn anders sein
die cdu ist die stärkere und größere
schwester und susi kann entscheiden ob
diese breite mehrheit da ist oder nicht
wir können ja nur ein angebot machen das
alles gemacht und die woche ich bleibe
nur mal die woche über echt wichtig für
alle beteiligten um ihn einzureichen um
stimmungen zu hören
um auch seismografisch zu erspüren wie
wie insgesamt sich die parteien
aufstellen ihre vielfalt
das ist in der csu natürlich leichter
weil wir kleiner sind und ein homogenes
land sind da habe ich auch großen
respekt vor den auch die
moderationsprozess den den den armin
laschet mehr führen muss geht damit über
nacht
es ist ja auch so dass schon sie es ist
klar gibt es zwischen franken und
altbayern ja gibt schon unterschiede ja
es gibt zwischen dem passauer und ein
paar schaffen bürger auch manchmal große
unterschiede zu überwinden aber es ist
nicht vergleichbar mit denen mit der
heterogenität die die cdu auch zu
integrieren hat und insofern ist auch
die jeweiligen integrationsleistungen
fall so ein prozess einfach anzuerkennen
anzuerkennen und deswegen habe ich auch
und es ist mir schon immer wichtig zu
sagen jetzt nicht wieder so der
klassische zu
es sei vermutlich sein könnte gesagt so
oder so und geht nicht anders sondern
angebot bereitschaft offenheit und wenn
die unterstützung da ist dann ja und wir
nicht oder wenn sie nicht so gesehen
wird oder wenn man sich anders
entscheidet da sind wir mit uns und ich
bin mir selbst wirklich sehr im reinen
dabei ich trage alles was ich hier sage
nicht nur mit meinem verstand sondern
auch mit meinem herzen voll mit und die
csu tut ist übrigens auch das ist ganz
wichtig also wir gehen in diese nächsten
wochen und monate glaube ich mit uns im
reinen und und auch aus voller
überzeugung ich habe aus vielen
gesprächen der letzten 23 jahren das ist
das was ich persönlich von dieser mpk
zeit auch mit angela merkel merkel
gelernt habe ist wenn er alles sehr
lange prozesse die meinem leben ich
kriege ja immer so ein bisschen den
vorwurf der markus söder der hat man
seine meinung geändert vielleicht das
was ich eine sehr beeindruckende aussage
findet den journalisten nutzen dieses
privileg sehr intensiv und zu recht weil
es jeden tag eine neue bewertung gibt
also dieses privileg dürfen sie ja ich
habe immer so das gefühl wenn man in
einem leben steht desto voller viele
herausforderungen sowie unser aller ist
aber in der politik natürlich im
schnellen takt
ich habe mal bei joschka fischers ein
buch gelesen da stand drin dass er ein
überzeugter pazifist war und das sap
arena seine einschätzung zu
militäreinsätzen fundamental geändert
hat das hat mich persönlich beeindruckt
weil jemand der 30 jahre das gleiche
erzählt er steht unter dem vielleicht
verdacht dass er nächste zu land und ich
habe für mich in anspruch genommen dazu
zu lernen und ein ist was ich gelernt
habe gerade aus dem jahr beispielsweise
zu 18 was für mich das prägendste ja
aber ich habe sie oft gesagt in den
wahlkampf und eines der prägendsten
linie war
cdu/csu nicht im total konflikt politik
nicht zu machen von oben mit druck
sondern auch mit der bevölkerung zu
machen und hineinzuhören das was nicht
immer der offizielle beschluss ist
sondern auch manche reisen
wenn wir am anfang nicht so leicht
gefallen das gebe ich offen zu aber ich
nehme für mich in anspruch und die
bundeskanzlei hat mir irgendwann mal
gesagt eine tugend an der ich heute noch
immer arbeite sei in der ruhe liegt die
kraft und die will ich jetzt an der
stelle optimieren und das tun wir auch
und deswegen sind wir mit uns und einige
mögliche entscheidung völlig im reinen
also ich hab das jetzt noch mal
zusammenfassen fragen darf so verstanden
dass wenn der cdu vorstand heute abend
einstimmig sagt armin laschet was machen
dann ist der armin laschet der
kanzlerkandidat
was ist wenn das nicht eindeutig ist
wenn es zum beispiel 60 40 ist im cdu
vorstand muss dann morgen das doch noch
in der fraktion besprochen werden
also ich finde ich habe jetzt alles
glaube ich sogar in der harten ja nein
fragen beantwortet und deswegen kann er
wieder auf so eine spekulative ebene
einlassen ich glaube das wird alles am
ende zugeht großen geschlossenen
mehrheiten so oder so zum ergebnis
führen
da bin ich dann sicher irgendwie wird es
am ende ein gutes ergebnis sein ich kann
das weder prognostizieren noch möchte
ich aber auch meier da irgendeinen
einfluss nehmen und mich einmischen muss
es jetzt eine entscheidung die die cdu
trifft und da deswegen sei auch der
grund warum ich jetzt mal sagt da halte
ich jetzt meine rede wir waren der
fraktion es war gewünscht von der
fraktion haben uns vorgestellt haben
auch auch mitdiskutiert und es war
glaube ich wichtig aber bald ist auch
das gemeinsame gremium ist ja das
gemeinsame gremium das einzige das
werben aber parteien sind sozusagen dann
an der stelle dann selbstständig und
müssen wir haben so wie wir es jetzt
getan haben und soweit ich weiß sind
auch parteien kein monolithischer club
gehörtes jahr an was so passiert und ich
glaube wir wenn es am ende gut gemeinsam
schafft also ich bin wirklich da
optimistischer
alexander kain passauer neue presse
bitte dass wir da sollte die cdu
entscheiden dass sie nicht
kanzlerkandidat werden würden sie dann
als spitzenkandidat für die csu in den
bundestagswahl gehen oder würden sie
dann sagen wenn ich nicht kanzler werde
dann ist berlin eher nichts für mich ein
kanzlerkandidat der kandidiert für die
bundestagsliste wenn man nicht
kanzlerkandidat ist dann kandidiert
nicht für die bundestagsliste ganz klar
timo frasch von der faz oder zwei fragen
wenn sie gestatten die erste wäre es
scheint dass in der cdu viele die angst
haben dass wenn die wahl zu ihren
gunsten ausfallen würde das dann auch
der cdu vorsitz armin laschet zur
disposition stünde sie haben ja nun in
macht angelegenheiten viel erfahrung
sehen sie das auch so oder glauben sie
dass er durchaus cdu vorsitzender
bleiben könnte
zweite frage gestern abend wurde ja mit
viel interesse ihre landung in berlin
beobachtet heute kam auf social media
diverse male die frage auf werden diesen
privatjet bezahlt habe vielleicht können
sie da auch noch für aufklärung sorgen
danke also zur letzten frage herr frosch
kann ich von seiten der partei von
seiten der csu ganz klar beantworten
selbstverständlich die csu das heißt wie
es partei weil es sich natürlich
erkennbarer weise um einen partei termin
gehandelt hat ist allerdings will ich
auch dazu sagen
die absolute ausnahme wenn andere
verkehrs möglichkeiten
aufgrund der kurzfristigkeit nicht
möglich sind wenn man schnell gerufen
wird muss man auch schnell entscheiden
hat wenn sowieso es geht und isst erste
das ich überhaupt kein problem
vielen dank und band soweit also markus
söder der csu-parteichef das war eine
ganze menge die er gesagt hat wesentlich
mehr als armin laschet darüber wenn wir
gleich sprechen auch nochmal mit nicole
diekmann unserer hauptstadt
korrespondentin vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz
wir können nicht alles zusammenfassen
aber ein wesentlicher punkt war
natürlich dass er gesagt hat er bleibt
bei seiner haltung auch bei seinem
statement von letzter woche dass wenn es
eben eine breite unterstützung gebe für
armin laschet mit breiter unterstützung
meint er vorstand fraktion und basis
dann würde er die entscheidung der cdu
akzeptieren und auch markus blume der
generalsekretär hat gesagt ja das
präsidium steht geschlossen hinter söder
und hinter seinen entscheidungen so dann
gehen wir vielleicht gerade noch mal in
medias res nicole also wir haben jetzt
sowohl laschet als auch söder gehört
sind wir schlauer hat ich finde wir sind
schon schlauer dass markus söder dem ich
gerade gesagt hat auch auf sagen wir mal
begründet misstrauische nachfragen noch
mal von den journalistinnen vor ort ist
er beugt sich der entscheidung des cdu
vorstands der heute abend das hat angela
seit einer stunde vor süder schon
verkündet zusammen gerufen wird so da
ist dazu eingeladen
das hat laschet um 13 uhr schon gesagt
das hat sie daraus später bestätigt wird
aber nicht dabei sein denn da sagt das
ist jetzt entscheidung der größeren
schwester cdu
die hat das letzte wort die entscheidung
die dort im vorstand getroffen wird der
werden wir uns beugen erbittet
wiederhole erbittet darum diese
entscheidung möglichst schnell
herbeizuführen es sei jetzt an der zeit
acht tage seien genug also womöglich
klärt sich heute nach den grünen auch
die zweite offene kanzlerfrage aber es
war schon fand ich deutlich zu erkennen
dass er seine vorzüge sowohl er selbst
als auch eben der generalsekretär markus
blume dass die doch noch mal gesagt
haben wofür sie da steht dass er eben
auch die menschen begeistern kann also
jetzt einfach nur zu sagen die cdu
entscheidet das jetzt ich halte mich
zurück
ja aber er weiß auch noch
daraufhin was sozusagen im schaufenster
steht und was er alles mitbringt ja klar
also markus söder hat sich ja auch
gerade nicht hingestellt und hat gesagt
ich ziehe zurück sondern er hat ganz
offensichtlich zeitungen gelesen
ferngesehen und radio gehört die
vergangenen tage und hat gesehen was
passiert ist nämlich dass das geld das
er in den vergangenen monaten von sich
versucht hat in der öffentlichkeit zu
zeichnen was ja auch gefruchtet hat
nämlich eines verantwortungsbewussten
fast schon staatsmännischen politikers
dass das wieder sehr gebröckelt ist in
den vergangenen tagen also man muss sich
mal vorstellen dass ein
csu-vorsitzender selbstverständlich ist
eigentlich betonen muss wie ich bin
anhänger der repräsentativen demokratie
das hat er ebenso gesagt und er habe
selbstverständlich respekt vor den
parteigremien das sagt markus söder
nicht weil man das so sagt sondern weil
der eindruck entstanden ist in den
vergangenen tagen bei nicht wenigen dass
beides nicht ganz ohne fragezeichen zu
sehen ist das heißt markus söder hat
diese pressekonferenz gerade klar dazu
benutzt noch mal darauf hinzuweisen also
es gibt eine nicht unbedeutende neigen
wir vor allem in der parteibasis mich an
der spitze haben zu wollen mich als
kandidatin ins rennen ums kanzleramt zu
schicken
er hat aber auch sehr geschickt sich
präsentiert als respektvoll ich weiß
nicht habe mich mit gezählt wie oft er
respektvoll respektieren gesagt hat es
war relativ oft in dieser
pressekonferenz als
verantwortungsbewusst hat einige male
darauf hingewiesen man diene dem land
und den menschen den wählern dann auch
das war in den vergangenen tagen immer
wieder auch in kommentaren aufgetaucht
dass sich da zwei streiten um eine
machtfrage aus reinem machtkalkül in
einer situation in der das land
angewiesen ist mitten in einer pandemie
auf schnelle entscheidungen und als
demütig also er hat versucht die mitte
zu finden zwischen es gibt viele die
sagen ich bin der beste und ich bin
davon überzeugt das heißt ich würde es
machen aber auch wir sind die kleine
schwester wir wollen uns dem vor
schlecht aussehen hier der grosse
krakeeler zu sein und keine
verantwortung zu übernehmen
der ball liegt jetzt bei der cdu und ich
freue mich sehr
und daran wird er da mit sicherheit auch
gemessen werden ob er das dann
tatsächlich tut also jetzt heute abend
18 uhr die vorstandssitzung der cdu und
danach wissen wir dann was dort
gesprochen und am ende wohl dann auch
entschieden wurde wir nehmen noch mal
kurz die zuschauer mit rein hat der herr
blume kohle bekommen für eine solche
verlogene aussage söder begeistert die
menschen im ganzen land wie abgehoben
und blind sind diese herren also
offensichtlich gehen da zumindest die
meinungen auseinander wir haben aber
links allerdings gerade auch noch mal
die umfrage gezeigt im
zdf-politbarometer und auch da genießt
herr söder tatsächlich und das ist eben
da auch repräsentativ hohe
zustimmungswerte also das muss man ihm
schon zugutehalten
ansonsten vielleicht gerade noch mal die
frage auch von john henry eben bzw von
willi korbmacher auf facebook muss sich
die cdu keine sorgen machen dass sie
wieder einen neuen vorsitzenden suchen
muss wenn laschet zurücktritt wenn söder
der kandidat wird tritt dann oder
mustern laschet zurücktreten ist ja
sozusagen die gretchenfrage die er in
den letzten tagen dann auch schon
mehrfach gestellt worden ist wie es
deine einschätzung dazu hat sich
wolfgang schäuble ja heute schon
geäußert und der diese frage mit ja
beantwortet sollte
laschet nicht als kanzlerkandidat ins
rennen gehen für die union dann müsste
er den cdu vorsitz abgeben das ist ein
schlaues manöver fand schäuble der sich
im übrigen letzte woche für laschet
ausgesprochen hat schäuble erhöht damit
auch den druck auf die csu geben
verantwortung zu übernehmen denn jetzt
schon wieder einen cdu vorsitzenden zu
demontieren
das würde auch einem kanzlerkandidaten
söder weh tun das heißt da hat scheubeck
waren sie durch die bürger noch mal
gesagt so jetzt passt mal auf schaut mal
was da auf dem spiel steht
überlegt euch gut was er da tut zweiter
einschätzung von nicole diekmann aus
unserem zdf hauptstadtstudio heute
allerdings zuhause fielen dann trotzdem
dass du dir die zeit genommen hast und
mit uns die ganzen dinge analysiert hast
vielen dank dafür und wir scheinen noch
mal
nach münchen denn dort steht mein
kollege alexander pohl der gerade auch
in der pressekonferenz dabei war und
markus söder live mitverfolgen konnte
vielleicht alexander nochmal an dicht
die frage wie hat markus söder gewirkt
für uns kann man relativ staatstragend
daher und auch irgendwie in sich ruhen
dabei ist von nervosität meinem eindruck
nach wenig zu spüren
naja so nervös habe ich markus söder
jetzt auch nicht erlebt ein kollege von
mir hat das gerade ganz eingängig
formuliert ihm klingeln die ohren so
geht es mir auch ein bisschen muss ich
ganz ehrlich zu
für mich nach einem sehr geordneten
rückzug lang und er hat das gesagt
angelehnt an das was er eigentlich
letzte woche schon gesagt hat nämlich
dass er ein votum des cdu vorstands
akzeptieren würde
und das hat er jetzt noch mal wiederholt
und auch auf die nachfrage ob er das
denn ernst meine hat er gesagt ja das
würde er machen und auf mich wirkte er
da wirklich ganz anders als in der
vergangenen woche da war dass er eine
kampfansage da war das ein seht her
nehmt mich ich bin der bessere kandidat
ich kann für die cdu besser mobilisieren
als armin laschet da sprach aus jeder
pore von markus söder in der vergangenen
woche
hier muss ich sagen habe ich jetzt
wirklich einen ganz anderen markus söder
erlebt der natürlich dann auch wieder
gesagt hat nein die basis muss schon
eine rolle spielen die fraktionen wo
schon eine rolle spielen aber am ende
ist es eben dann der bundesvorstand der
hier eine entscheidung trifft und der er
sich dann auch fügt die frage ist hätte
man das nicht alles schon acht tage
früher haben können
das war ja auch deine frage in der
pressekonferenz auf die er ja dann
geantwortet hatten also eine woche muss
man sich dann schon mal zeit geben um
sich ein meinungsbild abzuholen
aber was sollte ihnen dann jetzt dazu
gebracht haben seine eigene einschätzung
von seiner ja überzeugungs fähigkeit
auch auf die bevölkerung zu revidieren
warum sollte er jetzt nicht mehr glauben
dass er der bessere kandidat wäre ich
glaube dass er das nach wie vor glaubt
ich glaube nicht dass markus oder
annimmt dass die dass der zuspruch in
der bevölkerung für ihn gesunken ist ich
glaube aber dass wenn sie mich so fragen
ein machtwort von wolfgang schäuble in
der art und weise wie er es gesprochen
hat
da hat er ihn hat er markus söder
durchaus in seine schranken verwiesen
weil er damit gedroht hat dass die
gesamte union ein halbes jahr vor der
bundestagswahl ohne führung da steht das
ist eine drohung die muss markus söder
ernst nehmen der druck der sich
aufgebaut hat auf armin laschet er kam
tatsächlich aus der fraktion der kam aus
verschiedenen landesverbänden da kam
auch von einzelnen ministerpräsidenten
markus söder hatte hier allen grund
anzunehmen dass sich die dinge mehr in
seine richtung entwickeln aber ich denke
so ein machtwort wie das von wolfgang
schäuble haben ihnen vielleicht noch mal
zum nachdenken bewegt jetzt hatte markus
söder aber auch versichert wenn die
entscheidung zu seinen ungunsten fallen
sollte dann würde er armin asche zu 100%
zu unterstützen das war ja im vorfeld
schon vielfach naja zumindest so leicht
angezweifelt worden ob er das dann
tatsächlich dann auch so machen würde
wie ist da die einschätzung ich glaube
dass ich ja wenn man in der csu
die leute fragen würde was sie von einem
kanzler kandidat armin laschet halten
dann wäre das ergebnis in etwa so wie
die umfragen in letzter zeit die sich ja
sehr stark auch für markus söder
ausgesprochen haben ich glaube dass das
vertrauen innerhalb der csu in einen
kanzlerkandidaten armin laschet sehr
gering ist ich glaube dass nicht wenige
in der csu glauben dass er mit armin
laschet die bundestagswahl nicht
gewinnen kann
inwieweit dann sozusagen die kraft von
markus söder ich würde ihn als einen
starken parteivorsitzende ansehen reicht
um hier sozusagen seine partei auf die
füße zu heben zu sagen leute wir machen
jetzt hier alle gemeinsam einen
wahlkampf und legen uns richtig dafür
und zeigt das mag sein dass das
funktioniert aber den grundsätzlichen
zweifel
innerhalb der csu über armin laschet das
wird schwierig sein das aus zu hören wir
nehmen da noch mal ein paar stunden mit
auf wann rechnet er mit einer
endgültigen entscheidung und ich denke
das können wir jetzt noch seriös nicht
sagen aber heute abend um 18 uhr ist die
sitzung danach wurde nämlich auch
gefragt des cdu vorstands und ich gehe
davon aus dass es danach denn das wird
auch gefragt eine pressekonferenz noch
mal geben wird aber das ist jetzt wie
gesagt
es sind dinge die iren heute abend
geklärt werden müssen vielleicht auch
noch mal hier die frage inwieweit es
eventuell in bayern markus söder über
genommen werden könnte dass er jetzt so
offensiv mit dem kanzleramt geflirtet
hat ist man da in bayern er stolz drauf
auch wenn es nachher nichts wird oder
sagt man sich nur das aber schon schade
dass er eigentlich signalisiert hat
lieber nach berlin gehen zu wollen
nein das würde ich mir auf keinen fall
schaden
markus söder wird hier zurückkehren
jetzt bitte in anführungszeichen er war
er nicht weg aber als jemand der
sozusagen seinen hut in den ring
geworfen hat der gezeigt hat dass das
kann er hat die volle unterstützung der
csu ich glaube er hat auch die volle
unterstützung der csu basis für das was
er getan hat und dass er sich hier
aufgestellt hat dass er gezeigt hat
jemand aus der csu ist in der lage hier
diese zustimmung auch für die csu zu
generieren ich glaube das wird ihn hier
nicht schaden es wird im sehr nutzen
ja das vielleicht auch noch mal ein
wesentlicher unterschied also wenn sie
es nicht wird schadet ist ihm nicht oder
kaum und wenn laschet es nicht würde
dann würde es ihm massiv schaden genau
also die bei armin laschet genau das ist
in der tat so er hat sehr viel zu
verlieren markus söder hat gar nichts zu
verlieren im gegenteil wenn er hier
gestärkt zurückkommt und er wird nicht
als geschwächt zurückkommen man wird das
hier ihm als stärke aus legen was er
getan hat auch in den letzten acht tagen
übrigens was auf manche teile der cdu
als fast schon zerstörerisch gewirkt hat
hier wird es ihm als stärke ausgelegt
also da kann man überhaupt nicht davon
ausgehen dass er jetzt geschwächt
sozusagen hier seinen posten räumen muss
wunderbar das ist nochmal die
einschätzungen von alexander pohl im
livestream sagen wir normalerweise du
sehen sie es mir nach sie haben nicht
gesetzt dann bleibe ich jetzt auch wenn
sie alles lachen trotzdem von allen
anstrengungen das war sehr
und ja wir sind alle sehr gespannt auf
heute abend 18 uhr bzw dann im anschluss
darauf daran was daneben entschieden
wird bei dieser sitzung des cdu
vorstands so jetzt habe ich mir auch den
mund fusselig geredet
ich danke euch für euer interesse für
die fragen und kommentare und pflege
euch den nächsten live stream bei uns
ans herz wann immer der sein wird man
weiß es nicht in diesen tagen ist
überschlagen sich die ereignisse
danke für den moment und das ganz bald